have a look at the undercarriage I look
for dead shocks the feel of dead shocks
I want to feel some pressure some
compression these are feeling good one
of our wear parts on a snow machine is a
belt you can burn them up bust them blow
them all kinds of things happen to belts
so we always travel with a spare these
are our guide rods these are down in the
snow and we want to turn these are the
rods that make a turn these are
essential to steering so I always check
the guide rods I want to go take it out
and give it a real ride I want to open
it up we call it a shakedown you go out
and go find out what's wrong
right now I just want to check and make
sure the engine is running fine
and we do that by opening them up fully
for as long as we can you know anywhere
from like a 10 to 20 mile rides a good
shake down here we're always getting
ready our winters just started our
rivers just froze up we've hit some
really cold temperatures it's time to
use the machines so we've got them
prepared every time we get a chance you
know you just go out and get it ready
again add gas check your belts it's just
a very routine thing I like the engine I
like the drivetrain my undercarriage
sounds good my drivetrain sounds good my
engine is sounding good now I'm gonna go
take it for a ride across the tundra
which is a much more torturous place for
snow machine